we are going to be paying for this
scandal to the tune of 25 billion to 30
billion dollars a year
forever
i mean if some crook with a you know 38
went into a bank and held up the teller
for five thousand dollars
that bank would be they they'd be more
interested in getting their money back
than they would probably in in finding
and prosecuting the crook yet here we've
got 300 billion dollars and it's like
you know nobody can conquer them we
don't care we're justice department we
don't care
you know people we don't care where it
went i mean that's what they're
basically saying of course once they say
it you don't care where 300 billion
dollars went then you realize there's
something else going on here i always
found that anytime i found the cia
people involved you almost always in
fact
always found
mafia people there not only that right
in the middle of the snl crisis
thornberg the u.s attorney general at
that time
disbanded
the organized crime strike forces which
was
the the people that were doing the best
job of investigating the snl problem
i liken it to sort of a puppet show
this is the way i look at the way the
media
you've got a puppet show here and the
puppets are dancing
and they're making shadows on the wall
and what the public gets
is a reporter sitting in the audience
describing the shadows on the wall
that's sort of what we get
what's really happening is the shadows
in the wall being made by puppets who
are being manipulated by puppeteers who
are being told what to do by the puppet
master behind the curtain
you know and
and that's the way i kind of look at it
and and
you know what we need to do is find the
puppet master you know and describe how
it all works instead of just describing
the shadows on the wall
and somehow that i think that's the way
the government works too
pete brewton broke the story in the
houston post about the relationship to
the snl scandal of the mafia and the cia
he'll tell his story right now on
alternative views
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in her front page article dated february
the 4th 1990 houston post investigative
reporter pete bruton exposed an
explosive new angle to the savings and
loan scandal brewton declared that
during an eight-month investigation into
the role of fraud in the nation's
savings and loan crisis the post has
found evidence suggesting a possible
link between the central intelligence
agency and organized crime in the
failure of at least 22 thrifts including
16 in texas moreover brewton reported
the cia may have used part of the
proceeds from the snl fraud to help pay
for covert operations and other
activities that congress was unwilling
to support publicly
today on alternative views we have pete
bruton with us to discuss his research
into the great snl robbery to help us
unravel this epic story we have also
invited david armstrong the editor of
the texas observer who interviewed pete
bruton on the history of his research in
the april 5th texas observer and who has
researched the scandal himself so pete
and david welcome to alternative views
thank you
we not only
are going to hear from pete about the
extent of the savings alone crisis and
the participation of the mob and the cia
we'll also get his story about how the
story actually unfolded and how he wrote
all of this and the various connections
that were made and the people who helped
him with it
but also perhaps even as big a scandal
is the fact that the major establishment
media ignored the story
and the congress
whitewashed it in a little piddling
investigation they did so we've got a
lot of really good information to
present to you on alternative view
pete can you tell us where we stand now
with the snl crisis the magnitude we've
done a lot of programs on the snl crisis
the most popular that we've ever done
and it seems to be getting worse and
worse and the american people are
getting fleeced more and more
i believe bill seidman the former
director of the fdic in his last
statement
estimated the
total loss in a savings and loan debacle
at approximately 250 billion dollars
now that's just the loss itself to pay
for that loss
the united states government will issue
bonds
and there will be interest added onto
that and probably more than double the
cost bringing it up to probably 500 to
600 billion dollars
that's kind of hard to envision i think
a better way to look at it
is to realize
that we are going to be paying for this
scandal to the tune of 25 billion to 30
billion dollars a year forever
from now on because the bonds that we're
going to be issued when they become due
in 20 or 30 years they're just going to
roll them over and keep rolling them
over so this is going to cost us 25 to
30 billion a year from now on well we've
had uh estimates as high as a trillion
or so
far down the line and all the carrying
costs etcetera etcetera etcetera that
are going to have to be paid on it's
possible the only way we're going to
know the the end result is when the if
the rtc
sells all the property that they're
holding that's when we'll know how much
the losses were on the loans that went
for those properties
and depending on what the real estate
market does depending on what the rtc
does
it could
perhaps even double the loss we don't
know yet they're not doing a very good
job and they're having big problems
anytime the bureaucracy federated
bureaucracy gets involved in
in the workings of the real estate
market you know it's going to be a big
mess
and so we don't know yet but 250 billion
that stephen said is probably very
conservative what we do know is that
this is probably the biggest financial
scandal in american history and we also
know that everything the government
seems to be doing to make the scandal
better to deal with it is making it
worse
so that really this is an ongoing
problem they just don't have a solution
for at this time so let's try to unravel
how this all came about what is
ultimately the origin of the snl crisis
well i think the origin is sort of the
greed in human beings and and the the
circumstances that led to it
were the inflation in the late 70s
caused the interest rates to go up
and the snl's were then caught in this
big interest rate rate squeeze
where they had all of their money out in
mortgage loans that were low interest
five and six percent that's where they
were making their income and yet
they started having to pay 10 11 12 for
their deposits
so
in its wisdom
congress decided that the way you solve
that problem is to deregulate quote
unquote the snl industry let them invest
their money basically any way they want
to to get
big returns so they can pay for their
deposits
and
that
essentially
opened up the safe i mean it was a you
know that's where i look at deregulation
it opened up the safe to anybody who had
the temerity
and the
thievery in their hearts to walk in and
take the money out
because that's what it took
and you saw all of these two-bit
developers that you know
you know couldn't get a job at a bank
i'm sure
owning and buying and owning and running
savings in those like don dixon ed
mcburney jerry woods the whole crew that
we know
so deregulation just opened up the
vaults there are also a lot of instances
of
organized crime figures who actually in
prison track the deregulation
legislation through congress watching it
waiting for it to happen on the very day
that reagan signed
the bill into law there were instances
where
developers sat around a table trading
the same pieces of property around
pumping up the prices in anticipation of
uh the possibility of being able to
borrow against these overly inflated
pieces of property so they're they're
the people who were going to take
advantage of this saw this thing coming
down the pipe and capitalized on it once
it became available and they knew that
they wouldn't have to pay any of these
loans back because they were all insured
by the taxpayers right so they would
take or give their buddies or take out
themselves uh millions and millions of
dollars alone and default big deal i
think there were there were various
layers of protection between the people
who ultimately ended up with the money
and any sort of criminal problems that
they might have now where's this money
now obviously the people have it they've
they've squandered it in some ways but
it's also
still in existence somewhere right we'd
like to know where it is i think
sometimes i'm the only person that wants
to know where it is because nobody in
the government has ever indicated any
desire to try to track the money and get
it back for us and it seems to be the
first thing that you want to do i mean
if some crook with a you know 38 went
into a bank and held up the teller for
five thousand dollars
that bank would be they they'd be more
interested in getting their money back
than they would probably in in finding
and prosecuting the crook yet here we've
got 300 billion dollars and it's like
you know nobody can conquer them we
don't care we're justice department we
don't care
we don't care where it went that's what
they're basically saying
of course once they say it you don't
care where 300 billion dollars went then
you realize there's something else going
on here
let's focus for a couple minutes on this
cia organized crime link that's another
explosive
allegation that you made in your
research that there was some connection
between the cia and organized crime as
you said this connection goes back to
intelligence services working with the
mafia and the french connection in world
war ii and different uh events
anti-communist cold war
escapades since then but what did you
discover in particular about organized
crime cia connections in the snl crisis
how did they work together and what were
some of the common connections
we found that that
there were a couple of individuals that
were sort of
at the intersection of the cia and the
mafia
we don't know really you know who was
telling who what to do
um
we know that you know azima rinda bibi
courson
other people
in florida primarily
were working with the cia at the same
time they were working with the mafia
and if we tracked a lot of people back
to castle bank and trust
that have been involved in that scandal
which was a scandal in the mid 70s
a bank in in in the bahamas
that was laundering money for both the
mafia and the cia it was and it was set
up
by an attorney in miami named paul
hellewell
and attorney in chicago named burton
cantor
cantor had the mafia connections
hallowell had mafia and sea ice and
hello was part of the oss he was one of
the originators
yes he was
involved in the founding of the cia
and hellowell set up proprietaries for
the cia
okay now
we had courson here taking mafia money
from las vegas casinos down to central
america to be used by the cia for the
countries was is this the country
connection
some of it but it was going on before
that also it was going on in the early
80s
whatever they were doing else i mean
they were doing a lot other than just
nicaragua you know el salvador
a lot of places
um
you know it's a very symbiotic
relationship they both can gain okay
the the mafia can get to get out of jail
free card okay
and the cia can get
this the expertise that the mafia has in
laundering money
and also
you know the the muscle i mean the the
implications of
violence in addition the deniability
they're that they're one step away from
the fraud in that case do you have one
good example that can illustrate how for
instance crime guy organized crime got
in to the snl business and also the cia
connection yeah there's there are a
number of examples and i always found
that anytime i found the cia people
involved you almost always
always
found mafia people there now there were
some snl that had the mafia didn't have
the cia but it was everything you had to
see i had the mafia this is an old
tradition of course in our country where
the mafia and the cia do
dirty things together i mean it's
nothing new and nobody should be shocked
you know that
it happened in the snl crisis
we just had some indictments
come down 17 indictments about three
weeks ago
in a 20 000 acre land deal in the
florida panhandle
this was involving approximately 200
million dollars
most of the money came from hill savings
and loan in
red hill pennsylvania which was a
medium-sized snl
20 billion 20 million came from a little
savings and loan in the valley rio
grande valley
called vision bank savings
the money
most of them i'd say half of that money
went to the land owner that owned the
land that sold it to the crooks and that
st joe paper company which is part of
the dupont empire
part of the richest one of the richest
families
in the world got most this money and
what they did they used it to renovate
and upgrade a paper mill
in florida
instead of you know having to go out and
borrow the money or using their internal
capital they used this money
that came basically came from the
american taxpayers
to upgrade their paper mill
another 10 to 15 million dollars
went offshore
it was basically scraped off the top and
sent to the isle of jersey which is a
tax haven
banking haven in the english channel
the people that we found controlling
this money
and manipulating it were involved both
with the mafia and the cia
um one of the
the money launderers and a miami
attorney named lawrence freeman who
actually went to jail
for laundering money for a
dope dealer
who was also
part of the guns for drugs deal with cia
and the contras in latin america
freeman was also laundering money for
santo trafficante
the mafia boss in
tampa florida
so he freeman actually drew up the
land contract for the sale of this land
okay the man who bought it was a fellow
named william atkinson who was one of
these two-bit developers bouncing across
the country ended up in houston and all
of a sudden he's been able to borrow all
this money
i can't go into too much detail but he
had some very powerful figures behind
him
and
20 million dollars he borrowed from his
buddy robert corson who had vision back
savings courson was a what they call an
asset of the cia
he
took money
cash from las vegas casinos that were
controlling the mafia down to latin
america and it was used by the cia this
was another example of them doing things
together
of course and control this snl he got
probably half a million dollars scraped
off the top on this land deal
uh atkinson got probably a million
dollars scraped off the top st joe paper
got 70 million 10 million goes to the
island jersey
there is a
a
federal bureaucrat by the way who is
trying to track this my very courageous
very smart person
is trying to track this 10 million
dollars and
and he had been held up by the state
department
would not
get behind his efforts to get the
banking records in the isle of jersey
and the state department kept saying
we're not going to help you until there
are some indictments
well three weeks ago we got the
indictments
so maybe that will open that up there is
some indication
and that's all i can tell you right now
indication that some of this money may
have been used to buy weapons for iraq
robert corson also had some interesting
political connections as well didn't he
yes he did
courson used to brag that he had the
county judge of harris county john
lindsay who is one of the most
powerful prominent republicans in texas
in his hip pocket
and he
lindsey's largest single
political contribution
came from robert corson it was ten
thousand dollars
uh
lindsay went to las vegas with course
and party went hunting with him to
mexico
courson had a big party at his house for
lindsay one time of course now lindsay
is sort of disavowing any knowledge of
course you know and hardly knew the guy
and uh
in fact one time when i interviewed
lindsay about course and
one of the questions he asked was is he
in jail yet you know like i don't care
what happens to him now because he cared
a long time when he was getting ten
thousand dollars i noticed in your
article in the texas observer in which
you interview pete
that we see the same people popping up
here and there from one coast to the
other
with mafia and cia relationships and the
same people
there be some kind of scandal over here
and you see the same people involved or
maybe one step away uh people like
azeema or william beebe them the mafia
man
yes yeah bibi is one of the prime
examples in mario rinda renda brenda was
the money man on long island he was the
guy in his diary before deregulation you
know when reagan signed the deregulation
bill said i think we've hit the jackpot
rinda was following this bill through
congress just waiting i mean like the
oklahoma sooners at the line you know i
mean you know they had their track shoes
on just waiting until that bill went
into law and they were going to take off
and how exactly were they going to use
the snls could you give a sort of test
case of how they used the snl
deregulation to carry out whatever scam
they had in mind i like to look at an
snl as a big black box
where you don't have to worry what went
on inside it you you have the here you
look at the taxpayers dollars the
depositors dollars which ended up being
taxpayers i was coming in on one side
and then going out here they come go out
to the people that get the money
and don't just
if you just concentrate on that of
course inside the black box is where the
criminality occurred and that's what the
fbi and the justice department is going
to have to worry about figuring out
because this is where they falsified
documents and particularly the appraisal
reports but if you just look here's the
taxpayers money going in and here's
going out
that makes it very simple and then it
gives you a better idea of you
concentrate on who got the money
which is something that no one wants to
do the justice department doesn't want
to do it congress didn't want to do it
but if you look at that way who got the
money
then it makes a lot of sense and forget
about all the complex real estate deals
that went on inside the black box
because that's that was just done
to so no one could figure it out so the
reporters couldn't figure it out so the
regulators couldn't figure it out so the
justice department couldn't figure it
out and there's a lot of stuff that it's
extremely complicated but there are
people who can figure this out if you
just look at who got the money then it
makes a lot of sense
now we talked about just one or two
examples of uh mafia and cia
relationships what was the extent of
this how many
of these snls were involved with the
mafia and the ceo we started out i
believe we said 22
and
at the latest count it's something like
26 27 where we found
mafia people cia together in the same
savings
alone um
you know you're talking about deposits
of 15 billion dollars okay 15. this is
just the ones we've looked at i mean
it's almost as if any snl you look at
you could find some of these people in i
mean it was very pervasive
and particularly when you talk about
mario renda and herman beebe
renda and beebe both had strong
connections to the mafia and the cia
and they are all over the map i mean
render brokered money into 130 savings
and loans bb controlled at least
20
financial institutions in louisiana and
texas and did they take over the savings
and loans and therefore use the assets
for their different uh projects so when
they went broke they could just cut and
run because their depositors would be
employed would be insured by the fdic is
that how it worked or did they take big
loans out from these snls from their
projects with the intention of never
paying it back well
they did it very
subtly i mean it wasn't it wasn't like
bb would go in and buy a savings in loan
or rent
what i mean they controlled them yes but
it was two or three layers removed what
for instance look at vernon savings
that's a very famous example don dixon
dixon bought vernon savings
with a loan
from mbank in dallas
but herman kbb
guaranteed that loan and arranged it
so that dixon
was really beholden to bibi for the
money and in fact bibi had an option
to
buy equity in the snl because of his
guarantee of the bank loan
okay so here dixon is the figurehead in
fact
dixon had it arranged later
that he wasn't even on
the board of directors or appeared in
any of the vernon
you know uh stockholders support or
anything like that he was he had his
company
in the forefront so he had
even he was insulated from one layer so
he had this company called dondi
financial that owned vernon
you know and you look behind that and
that's dixon that owns donde financial
and you look behind dixon and you see
herman k beebe
you know manipulating him and then you
look behind me
bb and you find the mafia and the cia
and what would be in a way that they
would actually scam money from the snl
what would bibi and his mafia cia
connections do to get the money out of
the snls for their own purposes it was
basically one way they got loans okay
they got but it wasn't like a home loan
you know a hundred thousand dollar home
loan this is like 20 million dollar loan
on raw land
okay
that might be worth
a million dollars
and they've got all these grandiose
plans they're going to build a shopping
center here and blah blah blah and
therefore
say the land was worth one million
dollars
and bibi's buddy owned the land okay
so bb would get an appraisal
three million dollars
and that's that's where the cheated the
cheating really occurred in the
appraisal process
and i'm just astonished that the justice
department has not really gone after the
appraisers more to get them and then
flip them and make them turn states
evidence because that's where the real
cheating went on that's how you cheat
you got a piece of it it's so easy to do
in real estate because you've got all of
this
ambiguity about land values you've got
all this flex
so here's a little piece of private is
worth a million dollars you go out and
and you pay somebody
thousand dollars to say it's worth three
million dollars so you can you've just
stolen two million dollars and as simple
as that and if the fbi comes after you
you say oh this this appraisal said he
he says worth three million
i mean
i'm a you know honest businessman i
gotta go what what the appraiser said so
bibi gets a 20 million dollar loaner one
of his you know associates usually gets
a 20 million dollar loan from an snl
that bb controls you know like vernon
behind the scenes 20 million piece of
property is worth one million dollars
he pays his buddy that owns it three
million
okay and then he says i've got 70
million i'm going to develop this so he
he goes out and he might put a street in
or too look like he's and then he takes
the rest and he's he's adios he's gone
he's just stolen
19 million dollars
okay
and what are you going to do you know
we're just not talking about the snls
alone
involved with the cia and the mafia
there are some
banks regular commercial banks
absolutely there are um i think pete's
already mentioned at least one in kansas
city
there are there are several around the
country where several of these same
figures and and others involved in
similar activities were were engaged in
cia mob related
operations
and the fear is i think that there are
going to be more that the same things
that we've seen
as a result of deregulation of the snl's
may very well come about when the banks
are deregulated which is the which is
the current proposal on the table
um the theory being i guess it worked so
well with the snl so why not try it
again which is unbelievable that you
would contemplate that with the
grotesqueness or the failure
of these snl
pete can you
tell us a bit about how you developed
this story the inside story about how
the reporter uh came up with this some
of your sources and all this story
started the spring of 1987
when uh a business reporter at the
houston post greg c got a a call from an
anonymous anonymous call we didn't know
who the guy was
telling him to look into the failure of
mainland savings in houston
and so greg began and he got one name he
was given a name howard pulver
greg began looking at the
real property records to see the loans
that mainland was making to pulver and
his associates
and there were thousands and thousands
and thousands of pages of documents and
the city of the houston post asked me to
help greg go through the documents and i
really wasn't too excited about doing
that at the time
but you know i did and
we found out that pulver and his
associates who were from long island
had taken about a hundred million
dollars out of mainland savings
and and left mainland with promissory
notes on apartment complexes and these
were run down apartment complexes that
at the
time were probably worth less than 20
million dollars they're like 33 of them
so here you had 100 million dollars
taken out versus 20 million dollars that
they were worth
and and now
they're probably worth less than 5
million and most of them have probably
been sold i mean taxpayers took a huge
probably at least 60 million hit on that
so greg and i began looking at pulver
and his people
and who are these people and how did
they get down to mainland
and we went up to long island and
started knocking on doors and looking
into it we found out
that pulver
lived right across the street
from a guy named martin schwimmer
and schwimmer
was mario renda's partner that famous
name mario orenda
now brenda and schwimmer had brokered
almost a hundred million dollars of
deposits into mainland in other words
they had taken they were taking deposits
from people credit unions
uh things like this
right uh even
yeah pension funds from all over the
country and then placing them in various
snails where they get the highest rates
and of course randa was doing deals with
the snl's behind the scenes you know uh
you know you pay me 10 percent i'll put
this so much deposit you know and they
were all in what they call linked
financing
uh
randall would put the money in and say i
want to put this much money into your
snail and you're going to lend this to
my buddy over here okay
so here we had rinda and schwimmer
brokering 100 million dollars in the
mainland savings of medium-sized snl in
houston and here we have paulver and his
people taking out a hundred million
dollars it turns out pulver and schwever
are neighbors in kings point long island
which is a very exclusive bedroom
community in new york city
and we found when greg and i found that
out we knew we had a big story because
they had crime connections yeah the
swimmer in fact was even indicted for
for laundering money and buying bearer
bonds for for mafia so this was
organized crime just coming in from new
york coming into texas because they saw
a good target to raid yeah i you know
they weren't exactly met at the harris
county line by the sheriff either
these people
you they couldn't come into houston
unless they had had permission
from the organized crime people that
controlled houston
and which is the marcelo family out of
new orleans at that time what was your
first indication that the cia was
involved
well there was a u.s prosecutor in in
kansas city named lloyd monroe who was
following farhada zema who was an
iranian there was a contract agent for
the cia had an airline company called
global international airways oh that's a
proprietary airline of the cia yes i've
seen that yeah that is
quote owned that
and he was zima was involved in a bank
there in kansas city and he was a
director of it and it failed
the president was killed in a mysterious
one car accident
the president's right hand man was
anthony russo
a
disbarred attorney who had been
disbarred for
racketeering he was a mafia
fellow
and
russo also worked for zema so azima had
mafia and cia connections and lloyd
monroe who was a
a prosecutor with the organized crime
strike force in kansas city
uh was following his email and when i
was following renda
and i found renda at
azeema's bank
okay they're a little bank in fact that
was the first place rinda was caught
with his linked financing scam was in
this little bank in kansas city that
zema was involved with okay so i you
know i eventually got into contact with
lord monroe
and i would writing these stories about
the mafia and bibi and renda and i would
send them up to lloyd and he kept saying
you're missing something really big
there's one big area you're missing
you're meeting with he wouldn't tell me
what it was it sounds kind of like deep
vault
he'll give you a little bit but won't
tell you the whole thing yeah
and you know he was
you know he was
really being
you know a good prosecutor by not giving
me information i mean
when he left the organized current
strike force he confirmed what i'm about
to tell you oh i see he couldn't tell
you then legally oh he got old
i don't think he felt right about
telling me i think if i had found out
and asked him he would have confirmed it
but he put you on track well he didn't
put me on track i didn't know what he
was talking about
i was frustrated
and then one day after we'd been in the
story for a year and a half two years uh
greg got a call from a woman in houston
you see greg who knows greg c he was the
business reporter he's doing the work
with
who started chewing him out for not
digging deeper on this story in that
story
and greg and i went to see her
and she said she had worked for a man
named robert corson
who had a savings alone
and that courseman was an asset of the
c.i.a
in which i responded i remember that
time what's a cia asset
i didn't know anything about the cie
but
when she said that you know kind of the
light went off that was the big thing i
said i wonder if that's what lloyd
monroe is talking about
so i went up to see i went up to kansas
city to see lloyd and he confirmed it
that that's that azima
had the cia connections in fact
the cia
had sabotaged and prosecution
investigation prosecution of azima had
stopped it basically
had gone to the fbi
the fbi was investigating his ema
told him
not to that he's one of ours
leave him alone is uh this where the
term got out of jail free card that's
what the relationship is the fbi one of
the fbi agents that investigated that
told me that you know that they were
told that azima had it well
they weren't told
the way they do the cia when they want
to stop a prosecution or so they don't
go to the justice department they don't
go to u.s attorney they go to the fbi
the fbi and ci have a very close
relationship
and there are there are actually
examples in fact there was one in in
miami an investigation in the 70s of
guillermo hernandez cortana where
the cia went to the fbi and got them to
stop the investigation
but the fbi never told the u.s
attorney's office
they just shut it down
and the u.s assistant u.s attorney was
doing this was very frustrated and angry
and mad in fact he filed foi requests
with the fbi to find out what the cia
was telling them of course he was denied
it but they had to tell him
the number of documents he was denied
so there were like 20 of them
regarding cartagena
so the see the fbi can shut an
investigation down and not even tell the
us attorney's office okay it's because
of this relationship and that's what
happened with the zima
yeah the cia somebody in the cia went to
somebody in the fbi he said leave the
sky alone and so it filtered down to the
ranks
to hit the bottom the two fbi agents
that were investigating azima
and they just got the word basically as
one of the fbi agents told me
well
we found out that azima had to get out
of jail free car
there are a couple of interesting
consequences of all that one is
azima's airline global
global airways was the airline used to
fly some of the tow missiles to iran
um during the iran contra affair
yeah one what if actually one of his
sister companies called race
aviation which was owned by azeema's
brother i remember questioning azimus
trying to find out do you own race no no
i don't own it leave me alone i've told
everybody i don't own it
well after about 20 minutes of
questioning i finally got him to admit
that his brother owned it
so it's all in the family yeah the other
thing in terms of the the stonewalling
that the federal officials did in terms
of blocking prosecutions that has an
interesting effect in terms of the human
fallout trying to put a human face on
this story is often hard but there's a
very poignant case i think in in the
kansas city incident
one of the people who they were able to
prosecute when they failed to be able to
go after the higher-ups at the bank was
a gentleman by the name of fred figgy
mr figgy was a borrower
at indian springs and was prosecuted i
believe it was on 33 counts he had done
nothing more than borrowed the they
decided that it was insufficient
paperwork the bank had never demanded
more exact paperwork from from him or
the people who he was involved with for
their projects they were borrowing money
to to develop in in hawaii at the time
mr figgy ended up going to jail i
believe he spent two and a half years in
jail and and for two of those years he
went untreated for cancer
he was finally his conviction was
overturned on appeal
unfortunately he didn't get to live long
enough to see
the
final vindication he died recently as a
result of the cancer that went untreated
while he was in prison
boys play rough up at that level well
pete you started writing this incredible
series
in the houston post
but the big boys up in the washington
post and new york times networks they
didn't pay any attention to it didn't
they no they didn't the ap picked up
some of the stories
and ran them although there were even
problems with that sometimes the dallas
office of the ap would pick it up
and it would get run in texas papers but
for some reason the ap
people in new york city or washington
would not pick it up and run it on the
national wire so many of the stories ran
in texas but never
ran in the national wire
did you ever talk to them what was their
attitude do you think
i taught the ap and dallas they were
real gung-ho um i know that our editor
dave bergen talked to ap in washington a
lot
and really railed at them and they kept
promising and they were going to do it
the next time and they never did
i saw an article in the daily texan
which
was investigating this why in the world
wouldn't this be all over the
pages of the new york times all the news
of fit to print right and the washington
post in the nation's capital and all the
networks
and the people at the uh the big
newspaper said oh houston post that's a
nothing newspaper doesn't have any
credibility and who's pete bruton anyway
well pete what
what is your theory of why say the
washington post and the new york times
and cbs and time magazine didn't go into
the connection that you were making
between organized crime snl failures cia
et cetera because the snl crisis was a
big story by this time
it was being written about
nationally but
they missed this element
that you were investigating well i think
you have to back up yeah there were a
lot of stories written about the snls
but they weren't very good
they didn't go into any detail
it was just these broad overviews that
they got from their sources in congress
very few of the big papers
went in and actually looked at
particular savings and loans that have
failed and really dug down and found out
why they failed and where the money went
the philadelphia inquirer did a big
story on health financial savings i
mentioned previously i don't think the
washington post or the new york times
ever did or the wall street journal for
that matter ever did any original
groundbreaking investigative reporting
on the snl crisis why was that the case
do you think it's too hard i mean they
just you can't do it sitting in your
office in washington new york city you
have to go into the courthouses and dig
through the records and actually figure
out what was going on and that's just
not the way they operate they wanted the
documents handed to them by official
sources in suits so they've gotten lazy
i think yeah it's lazy and it's
arrogance you know
um couldn't there also be another what
in our story for what in our story then
we're not going to do it
we've got to break it oh i see how much
of it you think is the fact that
the washington post has had a long
relationship with the cia
a cozy relationship with the cia and the
new york times is the prime
newspaper of the american power
structure and the ruling elite
and they're not going to do anything
that digs too deeply and might
destabilize in the american people's
mind just the the system itself yeah
i think you're right and we could go on
about the washington post relationship
the cia it is a long
it's very strong catherine graham
very i mean she made a speech to the cia
i think last year you know and talked
about there are certain things that have
to be kept secret now you know
which is a very strange attitude for a
journalist
but
you've got to understand the cia
it controls a lot of information
and it can reward and punish
a lot of reporters in washington new
york city
you know if they want to help somebody
with a story they can do it if they want
to hurt you they can do it
okay not only that it controls a lot of
information about congress
i mean the cia is is is so
anti-democratic it's so inimical to the
idea of
free people and democracy because
they are very secretive they keep
everything secret and they oper operate
covertly
and so
you know
they've got a lot of information about a
lot of things that they can use i won't
say is blackmail
certainly is pressure
on reporters
and
congressmen
and probably anybody else they wanted to
so it's you just hardly ever see
original investigative reporting on the
central intelligence agency
well what about the government now you
would think that the government wouldn't
be interested in in investigating this
but they whitewashed it too tell us
about that well um the day after the
first story the post came out
frank annunzio a congressman from
chicago i believe
came out he's he's on the house banking
committee and he was going to do a big
investigation of this
and of course the nunzio had his hand
with an snl cookie jar
you know and and
he had big problems i think he was
trying to divert attention away from him
to something else
was he one of the keating fights no he
was okay but his his top aide
uh went playing golf with keating all
the time and you know so they there was
a relationship there keating five and a
half yeah
uh so
annunzio immediately jumped on this i
think he was told though in a way that
you stay away from this
in fact in his letter
eventually to the
the intelligence committee the house
intelligence committee he passed the
buck to them you know you investigated
the cia director william webster refused
to appear before annunzio's committee
saying i'm you know i'm not going to
appear for you this is a matter for the
house intelligence committee
and so
nunzio's people investigated some of my
claims and they confirmed the part
about azima and the get out of jail free
card
okay so that was enough and nunzio says
we've confirmed some of this
he kicked it over the intelligence
committee in his letter it was all about
the cia there wasn't one word about the
mafia and nunzio's letter which i
thought was very curious yes but now the
c the senate or the the house
intelligence committee is controlled by
the cia anyway
i think they're in their hip pocket yeah
i mean you know you just don't want to
buck the cia
because they they're so powerful
because they can operate in secret
okay and they don't have to tell anybody
what they're doing if you try to find
out they say national security there's
also a revolving door going on between
the committee
and the cia and
i think pete discovered quickly that
there was a there was at least one
character involved in the investigation
who who drew a lot of suspicion this is
a man by the name of childs who was the
staff director of the committee child
had been the comptroller of the cia the
man who knew where the money went so
there was possibly a vested interest on
his part to try to
maintain some kind of respectability for
the cia and not probe too deeply they
they conducted an eight-month
investigation at which time they they
decided that there was nothing there
worth investigating despite confirming a
lot of pete's allegations in fact the
cia
admitted
that it had
financial dealings with at least four of
the institutions i had named all that
said that was standard you know regular
the same way they say about bcci now you
know just routine financial transactions
gathering information right yeah and
that i believe
it said five
you named five in said five individuals
that i had named in my story
had they had had connections to see it
done work for them okay and i'd only
named six at that time so five out of
the six that i'd named they said yeah
they had worked for us at one time but
there was nothing wrong going on and we
didn't have anything to do with any of
this
okay now that in itself
should have sent
you know
the new york times post really digging
you know what they ran a story so
there's nothing the house intelligence
investigated there's nothing to it
i don't i don't even think their stories
talked about the four financial
institutions or the five individuals at
the ci itself that was unbelievable in
itself that the cia would confirm
that these people had connections these
institutions and these people normally
won't even do that i think it figured
there was so much information already on
the record that they could not plausibly
deny that there was a connection but
there's nothing to it
see i think part of the problem for the
establishment here is that if they start
investigating the cia connections here
they uncover the cia connections with
the mafia and with this criminal
activity so this is where you had the
major delegitimating
activity come in here i think it's
symptomatic that they just left out the
mafia
in
this preliminary
pseudo investigation i think there's one
thing that
everybody will say now that the mafia is
deeply involved in the snl crisis yet
there has never been a congressional
investigation of that not only that
right in the middle of the snl crisis
thornberg the u.s attorney general at
that time
disbanded
the organized crime strike forces which
was
the the people that were doing the best
job of investigating the snl problem
they were the ones that nailed mario
rinda
they were the ones that had you know
helped with herman k beebe and yet
thornburg disbands them right in the
middle of this this is absolutely
unbelievable there's a parallel that
george bush came in as the drug czar and
they were doing a pretty good job of
preventing the laundering of drug money
through monitoring banks that the money
was going through so bush becomes the
drug czar he's going to lead the war on
drugs as vice president under reagan the
first thing he does is to disband this
unit that was regulating the laundering
of drug money making it easy for drug
lords as well as cia or mafia or anyone
to launder money so here's an organized
crime unit that was doing a good job in
monitoring certain organized crime
activities and the government eliminates
this i mean how can you explain this and
it sounds like the mafia has the
government
in their pockets that's very obvious
they don't want to they don't want the
american people to find out how the
system really works and what you did was
open up a window
so we could see the system and they
wanted to shut that window real fast
because if the american people really
knew and found out how the uh the system
really works the american people
wouldn't like it they succeeded
incredibly effectively too because i
think the the end result of the
investigation
that pete was describing
put a chilling effect on journalists
respectable journalists mainstream
journalists could no longer go to their
editors and say hey i've got this story
i've been following up on this
there are these connections there's mob
and cia connections at this local snl
they the editor would simply point to
this investigation see congress is
already investigated there's nothing to
it drop it
it had that effect i think on a lot of
people that it that it put an onus on
anybody who tried who tried to pursue
the story from that point on
they would be labeled conspiracy
theorists are somehow you know
completely completely off the mark in
their analysis of what was going on
because
congress had conducted this so-called
investigation into these allegations so
it's only the alternative press such as
the texas observer where this has
been continued to be tracked then well i
think pete's continuing to do it through
some work of his own we have a book
actually coming out
on this do you basically tell the story
of your investigation
in your forthcoming book yes
the book is now with the publisher simon
schuster and we're playing with it now
and trying to get it into final form
and do you know if the cia's monkeying
with it behind the scenes
i don't know
i wouldn't be surprised i know that
simon schuster is
is you know dedicated to publishing good
books and i don't think that the cia
could stop them
from publishing this book
and i think the cia knows that so
they're probably kind of laying low
what do you think
getting back kind of looking at the big
picture what do you think this
experience
and your information and knowledge now
says
say about the
united states government and system
economic and political system that we
have
well
you know it's it's like a
i liken it to sort of a puppet show
and this is the way i look at the way
the media
you've got a puppet show here and the
puppets are dancing
and they're making
shadows on the wall
and what the public gets
is a reporter sitting in the audience
describing the shadows on the wall
that's sort of what we get
what's really happening is the shadows
in the wall being made by puppets who
are being manipulated by puppeteers who
are being told what to do by the puppet
master behind the curtain
you know and
and that's the way i kind of look at it
and and
you know what we need to do is
find the puppet master you know and
describe how it all works instead of
just describing the shadows on the wall
and somehow that i think that's the way
the government works too and the
government are puppets they're the
congregations
reagan was a perfect example of that
everything that he said and did was
scripted i mean there's a good example
of a total
puppet i'll just give you a little
teaser here
one of the main characters in my book
is someone that
is not a well-known figure but he's one
of the most powerful men in the country
and i think that i can safely say that
he can tell both george bush and lloyd
benson what to do
and his circle of people
i mean can both tell them what here we
have lloyd benson one of the most
powerful democrats the former democratic
vice presidential
candidate george bush the republican
president
and yet there is a there is a group of
small group of people in houston
that can tell both these people
what to do and we don't even know who
these people are i mean do you see this
is a failure of journalism that there's
no revelations into what the power
structure really is how it works what it
does etc it's a failure of journalism
it's a failure of government
it's it's uh you know
thomas jefferson said once if he had to
decide between
no government or no newspapers he'd pick
no government
i mean our founding fathers knew how
important information was
to maintaining a free society
and uh
you know we've we started we've almost
lost the but i want to say we've just
about lost the battle although we have
an alternative press it's probably the
best in the world
places like in these times the
progressive the texas observer tv shows
like alternative views get out a
tremendous amount of information
critical of the system the problem is
the limited audience absolutely i think
that there's a tendency in this country
because we're we're brought up with the
notion of a free press to assume that if
it's not in the new york times or the
washington post it didn't happen these
are the these are the main organs and
these are the places that people turn to
for information and television news and
so if the if these stories don't
penetrate those media if they don't make
it into these into these major
publications people tend to discount
those stories they tend to be
um shoved off to the side and and
treated as some kind of an anomaly or
that there that there's no credibility
behind behind these things
i i've had i've had
innumerable
opportunities to try to explain this
these stories to people and the common
the common theme is
why why
wouldn't the new york times want to tell
us if it was true why wouldn't they be
out there covering this
there's a pulitzer prize in it for
somebody well i think pete can tell you
that there's not a pulitzer prize in it
that this is not a story that the uh
that the mainstream organs want to tell
in fact i don't think anyone has ever
won a pulitzer prize for investigative
reporting on the cia
here the most one of the most powerful
secretive institutions in our country
and it's really never
you know been investigated or the
investigation of has never been rewarded
by journalists
and that brings us to the end of another
alternative views
we're glad you could join us again
frequently hear from viewers who request
a list of news publications which we use
on alternative views and also a reading
list for u.s power structure in the mass
media
if you would like to have these send a
stamped self-addressed envelope
to the alternative information network
po box 7279 austin texas 787 13 you must
send a
self-addressed stamped envelope
we also can provide you with information
on how to get some of the materials by
john stockwell the former cia officer
and some other materials relating to the
national security state
we would like to thank our crew who
helped make this program possible brian
lynch set the lights and did the audio
mark alban lisa funk and donald herman
where our camera people and barbara
burch
was our director
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network
po box 7279
austin texas
78713
so that's our address if you'd like to
write to us it would be mighty nice to
hear from you we get somewhere between
40 and 60 letters a week
and we'd like to find yours in there too
goodbye
you